.
Woah!
Für diese Tage lebe ich:
mit der Familie im Schnee,
das ist mein Paradies.
Snowboarden ist quasi das Yang
zu meinem Yin im SRF-News-Studio.
Als Teenager in Davos fand ich
dank dem Brett zu mir selbst.
Es wurde Teil meiner Identität.
* Dynamische Musik *
Klar will ich das
an meine Kids weitergeben,
den Snowboard-Spirit im Herzen.
Yeah. Yeah!
Doch was macht ihn eigentlich aus?
Was hält die Leidenschaft am Leben?
Antworten suche ich in diesem Film -
bei Menschen, die Snowboarding gelebt
haben in den letzten 40 Jahren.
Wir wollten uns abheben vom
Establishment, wollten Rock'n'Roll.
Es ist richtig explodiert,
die Leute waren bereit dafür.
... einfach frei zu fahren.
Das ist mein Lieblingsgefühl.
Ein Teil des Snowboardings
ist vielleicht tot.
Ich wollte nicht Ski fahren,
sondern springen, wild sein, feiern.
Wir taten wie die Schweine.
* Rockige Musik *
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Laax Open:
d e r  Snowboard-Event in Europa.
Die Besten der Welt
geben ihr Bestes in Pipe und Park.
* Rasante Musik *
Klare Sache: Hier muss meine Suche
nach dem Spirit beginnen.
Nirgends
ist Snowboarding spektakulärer
als direkt am Rand
dieser Weltklasse-Pipe.
Sprünge wie von einem anderen Stern.
Damn!
Je akrobatischer, desto mehr Punkte.
Das Spielerische aber, was den Spass
an diesem Sport eigentlich ausmacht,
spielt hier kaum noch eine Rolle.
Leider kann ich am Wettkampf nicht
so fahren, wie ich fahren würde,
würde es nur um mein eigenes Gefühl
und den Spass gehen.
Ich mache viele Tricks
für den Wettkampf,
einfach damit sie gemacht sind.
Darum ist es ein Puzzle,
das zusammenkommt in einem Run.
Darin sind Tricks, die ich selber
nicht so gern sehe von mir.
Aber sie müssen halt drin sein.
Die Tricks sind heute
auch so schwierig und so hoch,
dass volles Risiko dazugehört.
Die Gefahr dabei ist immer,
dass du oben drauf landest
und alles zur Sau ist.
(Mann) Das ist beängstigend.
Beängstigend ...
Macht es denn überhaupt noch Spass?
Oh ja.
Einen ganzen Run hinzulegen,
richtig hoch, technisch schwierig
und sauber gestanden,
das ist
ein unvergleichliches Gefühl.
Die simplen Sprünge, mit Style, mit
Eleganz hoch in die Luft gezaubert,
kriegen zwar
nicht die meisten Punkte.
Profis und Publikum
lieben aber nichts mehr als das.
* Jubel *
Vom Spiel mit Schnee und Luft
zum Spitzensport.
Ich frage nach
bei einem langjährigen Profi:
Wie sieht der Wettkampfzirkus
mit Distanz betrachtet aus?
Treffpunkt Funpark, Betonung auf Fun.
Ciao, Sina! Geht's gut
- Hey, Arthur! Ja. Selber?
Gehen wir shredden?
- Ja.
* Lockere Musik *
Flims Laax
gilt weltweit als Top-Spot
und Sina ist hier aufgewachsen.
Ist ja lustig,
wir haben gleichzeitig angefangen,
du warst 5 und ich 12 oder 13.
Ich kann mich erinnern, für mich war
Snowboarden damals eine Offenbarung.
Skifahren hiess immer,
in der Skischule
in der Reihe hinterherfahren,
man hörte immer,
was man machen musste.
Und Snowboarden
ist einfach die grosse Freiheit.
Man geht hin, wo man will,
macht, was man will.
Hast du es auch als frei erlebt?
Snowboarden ist für mich
die grösste Passion, die ich habe.
Es ist mein Lieblingsgefühl.
Ich kann alles um mich herum
vergessen, bin in diesem Moment
und habe ein Riesen-Smile
im Gesicht.
Du kamst schnell zu den Wettkämpfen,
dann ist es weniger spielerisch.
Du musst kommen und trainieren
und absolvieren.
Wie passt das zusammen
mit der Freiheit?
Ich hatte das Glück,
dass mir das Training,
das man als Snowboarderin braucht,
um an die Spitze zu kommen,
mega Spass machte.
Wir gingen einfach snowboarden
und hatten Freude.
Man darf nicht zu verbissen sein.
Das finde ich toll.
Sina und ich merken schnell:
Wir teilen diese Leidenschaft.
Darum zeige ich ihr
einen ganz persönlichen Schatz.
Schau mal, ich habe etwas dabei.
- Gut.
Im Jahr 92/93 bin ich
auf so was rumgefahren. Schau mal.
Schau mal.
- Hey.
Dein Baby.
- Ja, mein Baby. Boah.
Es waren gute Zeiten.
Wenn man andere Snowboarder sah,
grüsste man sich
und schaute,
was der für ein Brett hat.
Es gab die Leute
mit den coolen Brettern.
Meins war kein besonders cooles.
- Nicht?- Nein!
Aber man hat's dann
ins Herz geschlossen.
Denn es war mein erstes.
Hast du dein erstes auch noch?
Ja, ich habe es auch noch.
- Dein allererstes? Zeig mal.
Hey, schaut mal!
- Mein Kinderbrett.
Oh, für die kleine Sina.
Es ist gleich schwer
wie meine jetzigen Bretter.
Sina hat heute
eine ganze Sammlung an Brettern,
doch ihre Passion geht viel tiefer:
Im renommierten Gelben Haus in Flims
gestaltete sie eine Ausstellung mit,
"40 Jahre Snowboard-Geschichte
in der Schweiz".
Viele Leute sagen nicht:
"Ich fahre Snowboard",
sondern: "Ich bin Snowboarderin."
Man macht's nicht nur,
es ist eine ganze Kultur.
Da sind Magazine dahinter,
Filme, Fotografien.
Mir war bewusst,
dass die Amerikaner führend waren.
Was mir bis dann nicht bewusst war,
ist, wie viel auch die Schweiz
gemacht hat
für die Entwicklungsarbeit
dieses Sports.
Also reisen wir zurück.
Es war einmal: das Brettgefühl.
Seitwärts durch die Welt,
wie's einem grad gefällt.
Skateboarder und Surfer
kannten das längst,
als der amerikanische Tüftler
Sherman Poppen
1965 ein Brett
für das Surfen im Schnee entwickelte.
Snow, Surfing: Snurfing war geboren.
Ein kleines Brett, keine Bindung,
dafür eine Leine zum Steuern -
fast eine Million von diesen Dingern
wurden verkauft.
Auch der kalifornische Skateboarder
Tom Sims
entwickelte in dieser Zeit
ein sog. Ski-Board.
Hi, I'm Tom Sims ...
Er gründet eine der ersten
grossen Snowboard-Marken.
* Rockige Musik *
In Utah reitet Surfer
Dimitrije Milovich
wenig später Tiefschneehänge,
als wären's Meereswellen.
Seine Bretter heissen Winterstick.
Und an der Ostküste, in Vermont,
erkennt Jake Burton 1977
das Potenzial,
das im Snowboarden steckt.
Hallo, ich bin Jake Burton Carpenter
von Burton Snowboards aus Vermont.
Es gab diese Firma, die hat
ein Ding namens Snurfer produziert.
Ich bin damit
zehn Jahre lang gefahren
und niemand
hat es wirklich verbessert,
also habe ich selber etwas gemacht.
1981 treffen sich die Pioniere
in Colorado
zum ersten offiziellen Rennen -
und zum Austausch
unter Schneesurf-Enthusiasten.
Give each other a bit of space.
A nice line
and then we'll step back ...
Hier leben die alten Zeiten weiter:
Das Longboard Classic
in Stuben am Arlberg
wird auch Woodstock des Snowboardens
genannt, mit Brettern aus jeder Ära.
Da will ich dabei sein.
* Rasante Musik, Countdown *
* Heulende Sirene *
* Lachen *
Ein Rennen mit Massenstart,
rein in die Bindung
und dann irgendwie runter ins Ziel,
egal wo durch.
* Rasante Rockmusik *
Wichtiger als das Resultat
ist das Community-Feeling -
und das High Five
von Organisator Paul Gruber.
Hey! Ha, so geil.
Supercool, toll, hey.
- Das ist wirklich sehr cool.
Warum heisst es
Woodstock des Snowboardens?
Weil es keine Regeln gibt.
Jeder darf seine Boardlänge fahren,
fahren und kommen, wie er will.
Woodstock war ja ähnlich.
- Love, Peace and Snowboarding.
Paul war von Anfang an dabei,
also  g a n z  von Anfang an:
1982 zeigt er der TV-Nation,
was dieses Ding überhaupt ist.
Bravo, bravo!
Paul Gruber,
ein Lehrling aus dem Rheintal,
hat uns einen Brief geschickt.
Darin hat er total begeistert von
einer neuen Sportart geschrieben,
dem sog. Snowboard.
Da surft er also, der Paul Gruber.
Ja, da surft er,
auf einem frühen Burton-Brett,
entdeckt in einem Skateboard-Magazin.
Ja, das war 1979,
da war ein kleines Bild
von einem Typen namens Jake Burton.
Er schrieb, er mache Snowboards.
Wir dachten: "Boah, jetzt kann man
auch im Winter skaten."
Dann fragte ich meine Mutter,
ob sie einen Brief aufsetzen kann,
ob er denn auch
nach Europa verkaufe.
Dann kam einen Monat später
ein Brief von Jake.
Er habe noch nie ein Brett
ausserhalb von Amerika verkauft
und müsse mal nachschauen,
wie das gehe.
Einen Monat später
hatte er es herausgefunden.
Er habe das Gefühl,
das koste etwa 70 ¤.
Laut den Briefen, die ich noch habe,
und laut Gesprächen mit Jake
war ich sein erster Kunde
ausserhalb Amerikas.
Das ist jetzt das erste Burton-Board,
das es in Europa gab?
Ja, laut Jake ist das das erste
Board, das er uns verkauft hat,
das erste, das er überhaupt
ausserhalb Amerikas verkauft hat.
Damit kamen wir im "Karussell", da
ist noch der Originalsticker drauf.
Ja, "Fernsehen DRS" steht da.
Wir waren Burton-Fans
und haben es personalisiert.
Paulchen! Also du?
- Das war damals mein Übername.
Du siehst, es gab nur diese Platte.
Mit Hosengummis hat man ...
Das hast du befestigt?
- Ja.
Und das Teil funktioniert heute noch
und wird mindestens einmal pro Jahr
hinter dem Haus gefahren.
Erfindergeist war damals gefragt.
Das ist ganz old school.
Auch bei Snowboard-Legende
José Fernandes.
What is this?
Ganz am Anfang,
als wir noch nicht wussten,
wie man diesen Sport
überhaupt macht,
haben wir selbst Bretter gemacht.
Wir hatten einen Kollegen,
der bei der Swissair arbeitete.
Er hat uns Fliegermaterial
mitgebracht.
Wir hatten nur Bilder
aus den Zeitungen, keine Videos.
Auf den meisten Bildern
war etwa dieser Teil im Schnee,
in der Kurve.
Wir wussten ungefähr,
wie die Nose aussieht.
Den Rest wussten wir nicht.
- Der Rest war Fantasie.
Der Rest war Wellenreiten.
Anfang der 80er
kommt Snowboarding in der Schweiz an.
Die jungen Wilden wollen etwas Neues.
* Lockere Musik *
Snowboarden ist damals
nur so schnell gewachsen,
weil die Leute vom Skifahren -
auf Deutsch gesagt -
die Fresse voll hatten.
Damals war Skifahren sehr uncool.
Man durfte keine Freude mehr zeigen.
Die Ski waren sehr lang,
es war ein Müssen.
Dann kam das Snowboarden
und es war kein Müssen,
sondern ein Dürfen und Wollen.
Jeder konnte
seinen eigenen Style entwickeln.
Wir wollten uns abheben
vom Establishment.
Was Rock'n'Roll war in der Musik,
waren wir im Wintersport.
Wir waren anders, lauter,
wir trugen mehr Farben.
Die bunten anderen werden indes
nicht mit offenen Armen empfangen.
Anfang der 80er war Snowboarden
verboten in den Skigebieten.
Wir konnten von Anfang an
nicht auf die Lifte.
Wir mussten immer hochlaufen.
Und ohne sehr viel Bestechung
mit Schoggi und Weinflaschen
wären wir gar nie
auf den Skilift gekommen.
Doch die Bretter sind gekommen,
um zu bleiben -
und sie entwickeln sich rasant:
Stahlkanten werden Standard,
Softbindungen kommen auf.
Racer ready - go, go!
In den USA
nimmt ein Rennzirkus Fahrt auf -
und José fährt mit,
als einer der ersten Europäer.
1985 wird er auf Anhieb
Dritter im Nordamerika-Cup.
Das glaubte mir keiner,
als ich zurückkam.
Erst etwa zwei Monate später,
als ich auf dem Titelbild
des ersten "Snowboard Magazine" war
in meinem Piatti-Rennanzug.
Ich war auf dem dritten Platz.
Sie sagten:
"Wow, José hat die Amis geschlagen!"
Die,
die wir nur aus Magazinen kannten.
* Rockige Musik *
José Fernandes - in dieser Zeit zudem
Schweizermeister im Skateboarding -
wird zum begeisterten Botschafter
des Snowboardens in der Schweiz.
Du hast etwas Neues mitgebracht,
nämlich das Gleiten auf Schnee.
Jetzt ist es ein Sport geworden,
der sehr viel Anerkennung
haben wird in nächster Zukunft.
Wir wollen auch
eine Schweizermeisterschaft.
* Rasante Musik *
Diese erste Schweizermeisterschaft
findet 1986 in St. Moritz statt.
Im Jahr darauf folgt im Engadin
schon die erste Weltmeisterschaft
auf europäischem Schnee.
Und auch in den USA gibt's eine WM,
wo José mit seinem Schweizer
Hooger-Booger-Board den Titel holt -
als erster Europäer überhaupt.
Die Rennen dieser Zeit,
auch auf höchstem Niveau,
sind immer noch
halb sportlicher Wettkampf,
halb fröhliches Treffen
unter Freunden.
Wir fuhren Rennen,
weil wir dort unsere Kumpels trafen.
Das war der einzige Grund.
Wir haben die Amis getroffen,
Terry Kidwell, Craig Kelly ...
Das waren alles Freunde.
Man fuhr ein Rennen
und in der Halfpipe
und ging nachher zusammen freeriden.
Alles scheint möglich damals:
Paul Gruber gründet
die Snowboard-Firma Crazy Banana,
ein Schweizer Original.
Und José Fernandes findet neue Wege,
das Image des Sports zu vermarkten:
Mittlerweile Teil
des renommierten Sims Teams
kann er Unternehmen
wie Swatch und Oakley
von sich und seinem Sport überzeugen.
Weitere Sponsoren beissen an:
Ende der 80er ist José
nach Ski-Legende Pirmin Zurbriggen
der bestverdienende
Schweizer Schneesportler.
1988 dreht er in Neuseeland einen der
ersten europäischen Snowboardfilme -
als Posterboy eines Trends, der
zum Milliardengeschäft werden sollte.
* Treibender Popsong:
"Vicious Games" von Yello *
Uttendorf in Österreich,
30 km von Kitzbühel entfernt,
knapp 3'000 Einwohner.
Hier stellt die grösste
Snowboardfabrik der Welt
jährlich über 100'000 Bretter her.
Ich bin hergekommen, um die
First Lady der Branche zu treffen:
Donna Carpenter,
die mit ihrem Mann Jake
Burton Snowboards aufgebaut hat.
Seit dessen Tod 2019
ist sie Oberhaupt der Firma.
So this is how the boards are made.
Wie die Bretter hergestellt werden,
das ist fast wie früher, oder?
Ja, die frühen Bretter
hatten aber einen Schaumkern.
Die hier sind aus Holz.
Als sich der junge Sport
langsam durchsetzte,
wollte Jake Burton
mit seiner Produktion durchstarten.
Das Know-how war in Europa grösser
als in den USA -
dank der Ski-Industrie.
Zunächst wollte aber kein Skiherstel-
ler die breiten Bretter produzieren.
Er besuchte alle diese Fabriken,
und alle sagten: "Geht nicht."
Dann, mitten in einem Schneesturm,
kam Jake hier bei Keil Ski an.
Sie mussten die Tochter der Familie
wecken, damit sie übersetzen kann.
Und Herr Keil meinte: "Hm,
ich denke, ich kann das machen."
Heute sind sie die grösste
Snowboardfabrik der Welt -
und stellen nur unsere Bretter her.
Burton ist heute Nummer 1 im Markt.
Die wichtigste Entwicklung
hätte man aber fast verpasst.
Burton oder Sims?
Ende der 80er eine Glaubensfrage
wie Coke oder Pepsi, PC oder Mac.
Auf der einen Seite:
Jake Burton, zu Hause in den Ski-
gebieten der amerikanischen Ostküste.
Jake fuhr früher selber Skirennen,
er ist in dieser Tradition
aufgewachsen.
Ladies and Gentlemen,
welcome to the 1986
US Open Snowboarding Championships.
Snowboard-Wettbewerbe
sind für Burton Rennsport:
Tore, Stoppuhr -
und ein Look fürs ganze Team.
Man muss ja nur
die alten Burton-Videos anschauen:
alle blau-rot, mit einer Zipfelmütze
und denselben Boards.
Das wollten wir nicht.
Auf der anderen Seite:
Tom Sims, der Skateboard-Weltmeister,
der in verschneiten Hängen
einen Spielplatz sieht:
für Tricks, wie Skater sie machen,
für Halfpipes, für Freestyle.
Ich bin in der Sims-Familie
aufgewachsen.
Und Tom hatte die Vision, Freestyle
gross zu machen im Snowboarden.
Damit die Leute sehen:
Es ist nicht nur Stangenfahren.
Freestyle ist damals entstanden.
Wir wollten uns ausdrücken,
und nicht gleich wieder
in einem Gefängnis landen
in Form einer Wettkampf-Uniform.
* Rasante Musik *
Wir haben diesen Trend verpasst.
Wir dachten nicht,
dass das den Sport so prägen wird.
Doch dank Freestyle
hebt Snowboarding erst richtig ab -
und bringt
seine eigenen Stars hervor.
In der Schweiz etwa Reto Lamm,
den Überflieger aus dem Engadin.
Und allen voran Craig Kelly.
Was Tricks angeht,
eine Klasse für sich.
Als er plötzlich von Sims
zum Rivalen Burton wechselt,
sind Team und Fans geschockt -
die Karten werden neu gemischt.
Craig Kelly an Bord zu holen,
hat uns total verändert.
Wir lernten,
auf die Fahrer zu hören.
Bis heute sind wir überzeugt:
Fahrerinnen und Fahrer
sollen die Entwicklung bestimmen.
Erst als Kelly zu Burton wechselte,
fiel bei Jake der Zwanziger.
Nicht schneller gewinnt,
sondern stylisher.
* Verspielte Musik *
Style, Kreativität, Finesse -
Skateboarding hat seinen Brudersport
im Schnee stark beeinflusst.
Viele Snowboarder
lieben auch das Brett mit Rollen.
Ich zähle mich dazu -
und Fabien Rohrer ebenso.
Geile Session. Was, denkst du, hat
das Skaten dem Snowboarden gegeben?
Brettsportarten, was viele
vergessen, sind Ausdruckssportarten,
aus meiner Sicht,
mit einem gewissen "Spirit".
Ich darf ohne Grenzen
meine Sachen so zusammenstellen -
meine Sprünge, meine Bewegungen -,
dass es nachher eine Ausdrucksform
gibt, cool aussieht
und mir ein extrem gutes Gefühl
gibt, während ich in der Luft bin.
Als ich in einem Video sah,
dass die aus Amerika
plötzlich Airs machten mit
einem Snowboard mit Bindung dran,
dachte ich: "Da kann ich ja viel
höher springen als mit dem Skate."
Ich sagte:
"Mutter, ich will so eins."
Du kriegst dein erstes Brett.
Was machst du?
Es nahm mir den Ärmel rein.
Ich dachte: Das ist für mich
das Freiheitsgefühl.
Mit 16 ging ich
zum Direktor der Schule und sagte:
"Herr Direktor, ich komme
nicht mehr, ich höre auf mein Herz,
das schlägt für das Snowboarden,
ich werde diesen Weg gehen."
Für mich war wichtig,
hinter dem zu stehen, was ich mache.
Und das ist, Snowboarder zu sein,
und das ist bis heute so.
Anfang der 90er setzt nicht nur
Fabien Rohrer voll aufs Snowboarden:
Ein eigener Verband entsteht, der
rund um die Welt Events durchführt:
die International Snowboarding
Federation, kurz ISF.
Auf der Tour taucht
ein Teenager aus Norwegen auf -
und fährt bald alle an die Wand:
Terje Haakonsen,
der neue König der Freestyler.
Halfpipe-Contests und alpine Rennen
finden meist noch nebeneinander
und miteinander statt.
Nicht wenige machen bei beidem mit.
Der weltweit erfolgreichste
Allrounder auf dem Brett
ist der Fribourger
Bertrand Denervaud, genannt Berti.
Ich fand alpin super,
Freestyle, Boardercross.
Ich wollte mich
nicht spezialisieren.
Am Anfang war normal,
dass alle mitfahren.
Mitfahren wollen auch
immer mehr Sponsoren.
Der Sport wird trendy,
jetzt fliesst auch Geld:
Die Jugend lässt sich
vom Freestyle-Spirit mitreissen
und kauft Boards wie wild.
Die Nachfrage explodierte förmlich.
Die Leute wollten etwas Neues.
Die Boarder erobern die Pisten -
kreuz und quer, was die Skination
Schweiz teils irritiert.
Gern habe ich sie nicht.
- Wieso nicht?
Weil sie mir immer
in den Weg kommen.
Die sollen nur nicht
auf den Pisten rumliegen.
Man sollte Pisten für Snowboarder
reservieren, andere für Skifahrer.
Mahnfinger der Eltern zum Trotz:
Für eine ganze Generation
wird Snowboarden sexy.
Das liegt nicht zuletzt
auch am Bild dieses Sports:
Magazine und Videos
führen eindrücklich vor Augen,
wie schön, wie cool
dieser Lifestyle ist.
Mittendrin ein junger Fotograf
und Filmer aus Dietikon:
Patrick Armbruster, über Jahre
Chronist der Snowboard-Szene.
Das waren die goldenen Zeiten, die
Rock'n'Roll-Days des Snowboarding.
Was würdest du sagen, warum ist
im Snowboarden Fotografie so wichtig?
Es gibt ja nur den Bruchteil einer
Sekunde, in dem alles richtig ist.
Style is everything,
im Snowboarden, im Skaten,
der Jump, der Grab, der Tweak,
du musst am richtigen Punkt ...
Die Komposition muss zusammenpassen.
Das war genauso Fun und Challenge,
gerade für mich.
Man ging mit den Jungs raus,
kam am Abend heim,
die Fahrer haben den Trick gestanden
und waren happy
und ich hatte den Moment erwischt.
* Johlen *
Is this my hotel room?
Die Party danach ist Teil des Ganzen:
Das Leben im Schnee
will ja gefeiert werden.
Die Nächte sind noch lauter
und wilder als die Tage.
Dieses Gefühl,
diese Zusammengehörigkeit
haben bei allen
eine solche Euphorie ausgelöst,
dass nach einem guten Snowboardtag
das Endorphin so hoch war,
dass man feiern wollte.
Wir taten wie die Schweine,
muss man sagen. Also ...
Sex, Drugs and Rock'n'Roll?
Ja, wir haben dumm getan.
Punk ist ein abgelutschter Begriff,
aber er trifft es:
Grenzen sprengen, rebellieren.
Wir wollten nicht Ski fahren,
sondern springen,
wild sein, Party machen.
Man lehnte sich auf,
hörte Rage Against the Machine.
Das ganze Rebellische
hatte viel mehr Gewicht,
als wir angefangen haben
in den 90er-Jahren.
* Energetischer Rocksong:
"Killing in the Name"
von Rage Against the Machine *
Der Rebellenethos im Party-Groove
kommt mit den ersten Big-Air-Contests
mitten in die Städte -
Air + Style in Innsbruck
oder freestyle.ch in Zürich
ziehen ein urbanes Publikum
in den Bann der Snowboard-Kultur.
# Fuck you,
I won't do what you tell me.
# Motherfucker!
Das hat Folgen:
Mitte der 90er ist out,
wer statt auf einem
noch auf zwei Brettern fährt.
Dem Skifahren fliegt der Nachwuchs
buchstäblich davon.
Das ruft einen mächtigen Player
auf den Plan:
den Internationalen Skiverband FIS.
Wir sind aufgefordert von
nationalen Verbänden und Skiklubs,
Verantwortung zu übernehmen
fürs Snowboarden.
Die nationalen Skiklubs und Verbände
haben viele junge Snowboarder
und möchten, dass in ihren Reihen
Wettkämpfe durchgeführt werden
mit einem internationalen Reglement.
Ab 1994 verfolgt die FIS das Ziel,
Snowboarden
in den Skisport zu integrieren.
Hanno Treindl,
bisher Chef Skiakrobatik,
wird zum Snowboard-Beauftragten -
mit klarer Agenda.
Auf nationaler Ebene FIS-Rennen,
Europacup, Weltcup,
Weltmeisterschaften,
und das Ziel waren
die Olympischen Winterspiele.
* Lockere Musik *
Die Skifahrer, echt jetzt?
Jahrelang haben die Pistenplatz-
hirsche das Snowboarden belächelt.
Und nun soll ihre
gut geölte Verbandsmaschinerie
den jungen Sport der Freigeister
zu den Olympischen Spielen führen.
Strikt nach den Regeln der FIS.
Wie sonst?
Am Snowboarderverband ISF vorbei
führt der Skiverband aus dem Stand
einen eigenen Weltcup durch -
und wirbt sogar Sponsoren
und TV-Partner ab.
Das bringt die ISF
in finanzielle Bedrängnis
und die Szene in Aufruhr.
Wir stehen am Morgen auf,
essen Snowboard, fahren Snowboard,
wir schlafen Snowboard.
Das ist eine Lebensphilosophie,
die die FIS nicht hat.
Bei der FIS
kommt das nicht aus dem Herz.
Das wird nicht funktionieren.
Es war Snowboarder gegen Skifahrer,
die Snowboardrennen
organisieren wollten.
Das war ein Krieg für uns.
Bei FIS-Rennen kommt es zu Protesten:
Snowboarding müsse eigenständig
bleiben, so die Devise.
* Pfiffe, Johlen *
Anschliessend kam es in Pitztal
sogar zu Handgreiflichkeiten.
Deshalb meine erste Frage
an die beiden Herren:
Musste es so weit kommen?
Herr Treindl?
Was in Pitztal passiert ist,
hätte nicht sein müssen.
Das hat mit Sport
nichts mehr zu tun.
Das Ganze wird jetzt
auf einer Ebene ausgetragen,
mit der sich die FIS
nicht identifizieren will.
Wir wollen guten Sport machen,
Leistungs- und Breitensport.
Die FIS will einen Hut aufsetzen
auf einen Sport,
der sehr Lifestyle-bezogen ist.
Er passiert aus dem Herz heraus.
Er wurde von den Jungen
für die Jungen gemacht.
Die Besten bleiben der ISF treu -
Ehrensache.
Doch dem Skiverband gelingt ein Coup:
Das Internationale Olympische Komitee
nimmt Snowboarden ins Programm
der Spiele von Nagano 1998 auf -
und erklärt den Skiverband FIS
zuständig für die Qualifikation.
Nach dem Motto: Dabei sein ist alles,
aber alles läuft über die FIS.
Wenn sie nicht irgendwann
bei der FIS mitfahren,
sich irgendwie qualifizieren,
wird es relativ schwierig.
Die Loyalität der Profis
wird auf die Probe gestellt.
Es ist wichtig,
dass wir Fahrer zum Verband stehen.
Ich bin sicher für die ISF.
Ich gehe nicht an die Olympiade,
wenn die FIS sie macht.
Die haben keine Ahnung.
Doch je näher die Spiele rücken,
desto mehr Topathleten
beissen in den sauren Apfel
und schreiben sich
bei FIS-Wettkämpfen ein,
dem Ticket nach Nagano zuliebe.
Fabien Rohrer steht 1997
auf dem Höhepunkt seiner Karriere:
Europameister,
Nummer 1 der Weltrangliste,
Sieger der grössten Big-Air-Events.
Die Medien feiern ihn als Star,
erst recht mit einer Miss Schweiz
als Freundin.
Olympia will er sich letztlich
nicht entgehen lassen
und handelt mit Kalkül.
Welcher Contest ist am effektivsten,
bringt mir 1'000 Punkte
und einen Titel?
Ich wählte die FIS-WM
und gewann sie auch.
Ich hatte also einen Titel
mit der goldenen Flocke
und zugleich 1'000 Punkte und musste
den Verein nicht mehr besuchen.
Selbst als FIS-Weltmeister
zeigt Fabien offen, wo er steht.
Wenn die Geldprobleme
so gross werden,
dass es die ISF nicht mehr gibt,
würdet ihr FIS-Rennen fahren?
Nein, dann höre ich auf.
Auch bei den Frauen
gewinnt mit Anita Schwaller
eine Schweizerin
den WM-Titel der FIS.
Auch wenig begeistert.
Der Titel ist mir eher peinlich,
als dass ich mich freue.
# Don't you dance with me.
Einer aber zieht seine Linie durch:
König Terje.
Haakonsen, über Jahre das unan-
gefochtene Mass aller Halfpipe-Dinge,
boykottiert die Olympischen Spiele.
Man stelle sich das vor:
Der mit Abstand beste Fahrer
der Welt sagt:
"Pff, mache ich nicht."
Das ist Snowboarding!
Nagano kommt,
und ein Schweizer hebt ab.
12. Februar 1998.
* Lockere Musik, Jubel *
* Jubel *
(Originalkommentar) Und es reicht!
85,2 Punkte.
Gian Simmen ist Olympiasieger
von Nagano.
Alle hatten
mit Fabien Rohrer gerechnet.
Der wird Vierter,
knapp vorbei am Podest,
auf dem Gian Simmen ganz oben steht.
Tschau.
- Hallo, das sieht super aus bei dir.
Wir haben uns Mühe gegeben.
- Fast besser als früher.
Und das 25 Jahre später.
Du bist vorher nicht
sehr viele Contests gefahren, oder?
V.a. nicht erfolgreich.
Ich war 96 Schweizermeister,
Dritter an der Europameisterschaft
vor Nagano.
Sonst habe ich tatsächlich
nichts gerissen.
Timing is everything.
Mein Ziel in Nagano war ja,
auf keiner Rangliste
als Letzter aufzutauchen.
Ich reiste ohne Erwartungen hin.
Denn im Fokus
stand damals Fäbu Rohrer.
Er hatte vorher alles gewonnen,
er war der Beste in dem Moment,
er hatte
die ganze Medienaufmerksamkeit,
mit Ex-Miss-Schweiz-Geschichten
und weiss ich was.
Und ich reiste als Nobody
nach Nagano.
Das war eine Zeit,
in der es viele Umtriebe gab,
der Konflikt der ISF und der FIS
war auf seinem Höhepunkt.
Was hat das für dich bedeutet?
Klar haben wir das mitbekommen,
auch dass Terje nicht fährt.
Dann war noch der 100'000-¤-Contest
in Gerlos, den er gewann.
Dort haben alle gesehen:
Er ist der Beste.
"Warum kommt er nicht
an die Olympischen Spiele?"
Für mich war relativ schnell klar:
Bei jedem Wettkampf, egal gegen wen,
muss du dein Bestes geben.
Und wer gewinnt, gewinnt halt.
Dann wurdest du quasi über Nacht
zum Gold-Gian,
wie der "Blick" titelte.
Für die Öffentlichkeit warst du dann
der beste Snowboarder der Welt.
Ja, das wurde so dargestellt.
Ich selber war ja nur froh,
mal einen internationalen Wettkampf
gewonnen zu haben.
Ich dachte immer: "Was soll das?"
Alle weinen und die Medien ...
Snowboarden hob damals richtig ab.
Gian Simmen wird nach Nagano
wie ein Popstar gefeiert.
Olympia macht Snowboarden
endgültig zum Mainstream.
Jetzt springt alles auf den Hype auf.
Also: wirklich alles.
Ovo, eins, die sechste. Action!
Now, you can be a part
of Tony's Team Tiger.
Just practice hard
and start with a complete breakfast.
... for a feeling so clean.
There's nothing you can't do.
Clean is the feeling of o.b.
Tschau, Kathrin. Morgen.
Auch die FIS will
mit Olympia im Rücken Gas geben.
Expansion heisst die Devise.
Mein Traum -
und nicht nur meiner - wäre,
dass man aus dem Snowboarden
die Formel 1 des Wintersports macht.
Weltumfassend, auf allen Kontinenten
grosse Wettkämpfe durchführen
mit sehr viel Medienaufmerksamkeit
und vielen Zuschauern.
Ganz andere Prioritäten
setzt Berti Denervaud,
ab 1998 nicht nur Snowboardprofi,
sondern auch neuer Präsident der ISF.
Ich hoffe,
dass die Stimmung so bleibt,
dass Snowboarden ein Lifestyle
bleibt, weniger eine Sportart.
Und ich wünschte,
dass die FIS aufhört,
Snowboardrennen zu organisieren.
Der Streit der Verbände
spitzt sich zu:
Ein Jahr nach Nagano
veranstaltet die ISF
ihre Europameisterschaft
an den exakt selben Daten
wie die Weltmeisterschaft
der FIS-Konkurrenz.
Da haben die doch die Frechheit
und legen ihre Europameisterschaft
auf das gleiche Datum
wie die Weltmeisterschaft.
Wir machen weiter das,
was wir seit zehn Jahren machen,
nicht mit der FIS, fertig.
Als ISF-Präsident trifft sich
Snowboarder Berti Denervaud
auch mit seinem Pendant bei der FIS,
dem langjährigen Funktionär
Gian Franco Kasper.
Ziel des Meetings war,
herauszufinden,
welche Kooperation
wir erreichen könnten.
Gian Franco sagte zu mir:
"Wir müssen nicht gross reden."
"Wir investieren, bis ihr tot seid.
Ende der Diskussion."
"Wir werden investieren,
bis ihr tot seid."?- Genau.
Drei Jahre später,
als der Hauptsponsor abspringt,
ist die ISF tatsächlich tot,
sprich: bankrott.
Der Skiverband
übernimmt Snowboarding.
Für die FIS wächst damit zusammen,
was zusammengehört.
Das sind keine
verschiedenen Kulturen.
Ich sehe da keinen Unterschied.
Am Schluss sind's die gleichen
Leute, die wollen Spass haben
und machen was, das sie
gerne machen. Darum geht's.
Ein Teil des Snowboardings
ist vielleicht tot,
vielleicht der Spirit ein wenig.
Ich denke, dass es für das Snowboar-
den der absolut richtige Weg war.
* Rockige Musik *
Im neuen Jahrtausend lebt der Spirit
fernab vom Wettkampfsport neu auf:
Der Snowboard-Film
wird zum Herzstück der Kultur.
Fotograf Patrick Armbruster gründet
die legendäre Firma Absinthe Films
mit Partner Justin Hostynek.
Sie machen Schweizer Namen
zu internationalen Freeride-Grössen:
Michi Albin ...
... Romain De Marchi ...
* Rockige Musik *
... und besonders: Nicolas Müller.
* Rhythmische Rapmusik *
Die Philosophie von Absinthe:
Eigentlich die Freestyle-Skills der
Fahrer ins Backcountry zu versetzen.
Ich habe einfach die Fahrer
mit dem meisten Talent,
dem besten Style
zusammengetrommelt.
Einen eigenen Style
haben auch die Filmemacher:
Helikopter etwa
sind mehr als Transportmittel,
sie sind Teil der Action.
Ich würde schon behaupten:
Das waren mit
die ersten Helikopteraufnahmen.
Wir hingen unter dem Helikopter
an Seilen,
damals gab es noch keine Drohnen.
Wir mussten uns teils
aus dem Helikopter rauslehnen
und mit der 16-mm-Kamera
voll draufhalten, möglichst stabil.
Und den Fahrern mit 10-20 m Distanz
mit dem Helikopter folgen.
# Going on, feeling strong.
I quit my job blowing ...
Ein leichtfüssiger Aargauer fliegt
mit Absinthe in ungekannte Sphären.
# Freedom rock slimeball
talking in code.
# We went down, lit up the shack.
Grabbed me a beer out of the sack.
# Everybody bent over twice.
Nicolas Müller wird zur Style-Ikone,
nicht nur für den Filmer.
Nicolas wurde während mehrerer Jahre
mehrmals bei vielen Magazinen
zum besten Snowboarder der Welt
gekürt,
obwohl er nie
bei einer Olympiade mitgemacht hat.
Unvergleichlich,
wie er snowboarden konnte:
Das Gefühl für das Brett
und das Gelände,
kombiniert mit Freestyle,
das ist einmalig.
Sogar Shaun White, der für jedermann
ein Begriff ist, sagte:
Wenn er sich aussuchen könnte,
wie er snowboarden kann,
dann wie Nicolas Müller.
Der Kontrast zwischen beiden
könnte grösser kaum sein:
Shaun White wird
mit seinen Olympiasiegen in Turin
und später in Vancouver zum hoch
bezahlten Megastar des Snowboardings.
Er gehört zu einer
neuen Generation Fahrer,
die voll auf eine Disziplin
und voll auf Wettkampf setzt.
Dazu zählt auch
der Schweizer Iouri Podladtchikov,
der 2014 in Sotschi
Halfpipe-Gold gewinnt.
Jetzt muss er
den Yolo-Flip auspacken.
Da ist er, der Yolo-Flip!
- Er steht ihn!
Podladtchikov ist Olympiasieger!
Ich glaube, ich falle gleich um.
Überhaupt umwerfend sind die
Schweizer Olympia-Erfolge bis heute:
der Doppelsieg der Brüder
Philipp und Simon Schoch z.B.
oder der Jubel
der glücklichen Gewinnerin
des ersten Golds im Boardercross,
Tanja Frieden.
Ich hatte von Beginn weg das Gefühl:
So ein Plämpu
wäre schon ziemlich cool.
Mit acht Gold-"Plämpu"
ist die Schweiz
heute bei Olympia hinter den USA
zweitbeste Snowboard-Nation.
Auf heimischen Pisten aber
ein anderes Bild.
Während für Snowboards
die Verkaufszahlen stagnieren,
steigen sie für Carvingski stark an.
Mit dem Carver erlebt der Skifahrer
mit sehr wenig Kraftaufwand
ein ähnliches Fahrgefühl
wie der Snöber.
Wir hatten Skitechnologie
in den 80ern geklaut,
in den Nullerjahren
klaute die Ski-Industrie bei uns.
Noch in den letzten Jahren wollten
die Kids nur noch Snowboard fahren,
aber jetzt,
mit den taillierten Latten,
steigen schon viele Trendsetter
auf die kurzen Carvingski um.
Das Board ist weg.
Ich brauche es nie mehr.
* Rockige Musik *
Nicht nur die Technologie, auch
der Snowboard-Style wird kopiert:
Freeskier wie Andri Ragettli
tragen die gleichen Outfits
und machen die gleichen Tricks
in Pipe und Park.
Ehrlich gesagt haben wir wohl
eine Generation verloren,
v.a. in der Schweiz.
Kids, die Snowboarden
als Sport von gestern sahen.
Freeskiing kam auf.
Aber ich denke, sie kommen zurück.
Surfen im Schnee
macht einfach so viel Spass.
Oder auch Skaten im Schnee,
weit weg vom nächsten Skigebiet.
* Rockige Musik *
Ein Februarmorgen
im Neuenburger Jura.
In Le Locle sehen die wenigsten
ein Schneesportparadies,
Street-Snowboarder hingegen schon.
Dass sie ihre Filme
ausgerechnet in Städten drehen,
ist teils erklärungsbedürftig.
Uns ist auch
schon mehrmals passiert,
dass jemand gerade
einen Trick gemacht hatte
und 5 Min. später
kam der Hausmeister und war wütend.
Was sagen die Leute denn so?
Ähm ...
"Habt ihr eine Bewilligung dafür?"
Bewilligung gibt's nicht,
Begeisterung dafür umso mehr.
Auch wenn's viel Arbeit braucht,
die passende Stelle erst zu finden
und dann bereit zu machen
für einen Snowboard-Trick.
Für Filmer Lou Staub hat urbane
Architektur ihren eigenen Reiz.
Warum tut man sich das an?
Man könnte ja einfach auf einen Berg
hoch, in irgendein Skigebiet gehen.
Auf dem Berg fährt man halt einfach,
was einem vorgegeben wird,
was im Snowpark gebaut wurde.
Und hier ...
Hier fährt man an einer Wand,
bei der niemand
an Snowboarden gedacht hat.
Ja, hier kann der Rider sagen, was
er cool findet und fahren möchte.
Man kann machen, was man will,
und es so festhalten, wie man will.
Aber die Strasse ist schon etwas
gefährlich, nicht? Mit dem Drop.
Da kommt noch Schnee hin.
- Muss es denn gefährlich sein?
Nun, es muss schon einen Wow-Faktor
haben, wenn man es anschaut.
Der Wow-Trick heute heisst Wallride.
Entlang der Wand einer Turnhalle.
Etwas für den Schweizer
Street-Spezialisten Gian Sutter.
Der andere war viel schöner.
- Hier war ich schneller weg.
Vom Ansatz her ist das ja ein Zurück
zu den Wurzeln des Skateboardings,
irgendwo in einer Stadt
Dinge zu nutzen,
die dafür nicht gebaut sind?
Ja, mega. Fast alle Inspiration
kommt momentan vom Skaten.
Wir skaten auch alle im Sommer.
So hat unsere Crew Street-Snow-
boarding überhaupt kennengelernt.
Es ist aussergewöhnlich,
dass wir mit den Schweizer Alpen
nicht die Berge runterfahren,
sondern in Städte gehen,
wo es selten Schnee gibt.
Was ist mit Contests?
- Nein.- Warum nicht?
Ich habe das früher gemacht.
Beides hat keinen Platz mehr.
Hier habe ich viel mehr Freiheit,
es macht mehr Spass,
Kreativität auszudrücken.
Für den perfekten Clip braucht es
so viele Anläufe, wie's halt braucht.
# Woop-woop,
that's the sound of da police.
that's the sound of da beast.
Auch das kennt die Crew.
Man erläutert freundlich,
dass hier eigentlich
ein Stück Kultur entsteht
und alles aufgeräumt wird.
Die Staatsgewalt gibt ihr Okay.
* Rhythmischer Hip-Hop *
Ja! Im Kasten.
Der war noch besser als der vorher.
Hier in den Strassen, weit weg von
jedem Wettkampf, jeder Gondelbahn,
ist Snowboarding so rebellisch
und roh wie in den frühen Jahren.
Allerdings definitiv nur was
für junge Knochen.
* Düstere Musik *
Für ältere Rider wie mich
liegt der Kick woanders:
nicht härter, sondern simpler -
weglassen, was es nicht braucht.
Beim Snowboard ist das die Bindung:
Powsurfing funktioniert im Tiefschnee
ganz ohne festgeschnallte Füsse.
Ich kenne einen, der auch
bei Schneegestöber voll dabei ist:
Pionier Paul Gruber. Hey, Paul.
- Hey, Arthur. Servus.
Good to see you.
- Schön, dass du da bist.
Gut, dich wiederzusehen. Wollen wir
ein wenig surfen im Schnee?
Das richtige Wetter haben wir ja.
- Und die richtigen Bretter.
Sie erinnern an die Bretter,
die ihr früher hattet.
Nur dass die Schnur vorne war.
- Nun ist sie am Bein.
Nur dazu da,
dass das Brett nicht abhaut.
Das wird wohl trotzdem passieren -
egal.
Das ist uns egal, wir legen los!
- Let's go!
* Rockige Musik *
Yeah! Wir sind so geil!
Voll lebendig.
Yeah, rock, man!
Wenn meine Suche nach der Seele
im Snowboarding eins gezeigt hat,
dann, dass es mehr nicht braucht:
ein Brett, etwas Schnee
und keine Regeln.
Denn Freiheit bedeutet,
dass jeder und jede -
egal wie, egal wo, egal wie alt -
eine eigene Welt entdecken kann.
Den Spirit hat es nicht verloren,
auch heute nicht.
Ich liebe es immer noch:
jeden Tag auf dem Brett.
Es ist wie ein Virus, das sich
eingepflanzt hat und mich verfolgt.
Und auch die ganze Community,
die Freunde,
die man durch das Snowboarden
gewinnt.
Das ist für mich
das Freiheitsgefühl.
... den ganzen Berg
als Spielplatz zu sehen.
Für mich ist es immer noch
der beste Sport der Welt.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Madeleine Gassner - 2023